catch a boy psycho here starting the
quest Boston after dark and he's got his
main man Donald shop right here Sam see
ya happy idea idea and I do this I don't
know okay well let's do this okay
flicking [ __ ] faster but you're not
oh here we go thank you
yeah that's after [ __ ] yeah I connect to
the station listen up everyone this is
whisper he did the switchboard off with
deacon he's a full agent effective oh
I'm County Oh Pam ropes feel free to
welcome him aboard that is all what is
it it's not an easy road you've chosen
but you're never alone in this Oh tinker
Tom's got me ru is doing jumped yeah
West fire Desdemona told me to give you
this an extraordinary feat to recover
this but that's hardly the point without
a lick of training and us knowing hardly
anything about you deserts invited you
to join a jacket would have been nice if
she had hair to help tell me what you
need one of our field agents old man
stopped in so headquarters as paranoid
old bat won't even tell that's stare
that I can it is up the dead drop is a
mailbox with the rails it's a common
means of communicating when you make
contact with Stockton evil the current
sign is do you have a Geiger counter and
the counter is yes yes you can trust me
with the just don't bollocks it up
Stockton is a prominent use the escape
tunnel in the back strongly decision
what is that tell me okay tell me what
you decided our decision for strong Dean
control head I sent you good fighter
good a super mutant fight beside strong
many ties yes yes you good leader better
than fish I can't strong follow you
always that can you now Strong's leader
thank you thank you I am awesome use the
back entrance too much traffic to the
church and we'll burn this hideout like
that okay whoever I got to go the dead
you're up let's do this
good place for fighting good firefighter
now we're here to kill some [ __ ] okay
okay save save save the [ __ ] we gotta go
but just where the [ __ ] we gotta go it
old man Stockton okay where the [ __ ] is
that Oh close though
let me see use the back entrance where
is it where is it okay okay
all right watch this
did you see Mia I can't tell now you
didn't see it i think god
yeah [ __ ] and badge like noise oh we
[ __ ] dick wats
okay a lot of commotion going on here
like a combat zone or something oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] long girl
who your egg binder that [ __ ] it's
the Alpha
like I got a fair where the [ __ ] I'm
going
oh I've been here wait Helen I don't
know maybe one making this up yeah it
happened here this is when I was like
taking out those like leaders ok is
gonna figure out what the [ __ ] is going
on over there does anyone [ __ ] it down
no I don't like the Brotherhood of Steel
there to like alpha you know welcome my
friend might I ask do you have a Geiger
counter Tanis I nine is in the shop you
you're with arm you are let's say yeah
of course it's just and I can show all
you need to know so maintaining okay
okay a traitor exact my current i'm
supposed to deliver the patrick
facilitate we're supposed to make ok
where is there are David point
yeah I got a [ __ ] I shouldn't move this
whole thing to the bathroom sucking like
[ __ ] and play and [ __ ] and play and [ __ ]
and play and piss and play and then [ __ ]
and play it's weird like we'll see you
appiy more than a [ __ ] but I shouldn't
with IP is that weird I don't know you
know who's a doctor here no and this is
your tip okay like we got that so you
got this Oh baby I'm ma I'm here to
secure yeah bit 80 what's up [ __ ] yes
yes you like that that's a huge [ __ ]
beast
okay I'm running I'm running I get in
here you can't key can't follow me it's
too big
lighting him up though Jesus look [ __ ]
a I didn't get any experience rat you
[ __ ] [ __ ] ok ok I gotta secure the
drop zone you know aki fight the
territory fight the hood and gain more
hood ok ok dad kit kat i saw a feature
pitches he's mutating [ __ ] that man
Thank You meets at all you [ __ ] once
but seconds I have a laser
wait on tonight no prob on baby no
problem I'm a big quick saver okay wait
until tile 12 Oh everyone's here I'm
from what I've been told it's probably
safer if I don't say anything oh yeah I
don't want to put you in any more danger
okay well yeah but okay hey everything
looks clear this is h2 2282 here's the
person I talk to you about nice to meet
you another person actually happy to
meet remember what I told you i'll fire
up the signal okay fire on the segno
[ __ ] and they are time for me to go
keep h2 safe someone will be here
shortly
keep him safe what the [ __ ] kind of job
is s
how much blew that bitch's brain off
easy there don't shoot whisper right I
heard about you walk the freedom trail
nice to meet ya but do you have a Geiger
counter right you are mine is in the
shop oh good now yeah yeah let's take a
look at our friend hey you you okay a
little rattled but I've never been
better the other man he told you right
age to you need a real oh listen there's
more than Raiders ok I clan Raiders not
your headquarter sure need to get to
ticonderoga a lot of sense fresh off the
boat all right I'll lead the way ok
let's do this better eyes let's do this
[ __ ] ok ok all right
what
you
no fight today
let's do this okay imma starless another
all right time okay supposedly another
guy running around over there okay I
wait till he gets close and then I fire
yeah didn't get the swing yet
come on God God cut God cut gun I'd cut
gonna miss ah that's good [ __ ] i [ __ ]
miss anything in here jay says
let me get that picture quick and just
do the last this thing what do I need
level 41 that's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's my
curse more like all the way up strength
it's in Dorrit's oh sure wait no back up
a neat gun nut don't I okay where we
going brother where are we going
highrise you can catch up its icon just
got to make it there alive first
which way this brother's going ok that's
right what's right
hi right catch up its icon just gotta
make that
[ __ ] here is that spikes that's too is
this yes thank you me hey i right and
we're here all in the nights work for
you agent types yeah yeah yeah this is
is a just part of this or I think I'm
gonna like you if you ever need grub
well it's just a power net but right now
Leia okay how the [ __ ] do I get to there
we go that's a crazy good
if sweaty people I get the [ __ ] out of
my face jay says get huh hey Doc hey
thanks so much